Let's add delegation to the record
sounds view controller.
First we have to tell Xcode that our
record sounds view controller conforms
to the AVAudioRecorder
delegate protocol.
That is to say.
we'll implementing a function described
in that delegate protocol, and
our view controller can act as
the delegate for AVAudioRecorder.
And the RecordSoundsViewController.swift
file, go to the class declaration and
indicate that we conform to
the AV audio recorder delegate,
by adding it here after
UIViewController.
A class in Swift can only inherit
from a single superclass, but
it can conform to as many
protocols as you want.
You just have to list them
here separated by a comma.
Next we have to tell the a.v.
audio recorder that the record sound
view controller can act as its delegate.
In the record audio function we
can set our view controller self
as a delegate to the a.v.
Audio recorder with this line.
Scroll down to the bottom of the record
sounds view controller.swift file.
Because we've already informed Xcode.
That our record sounds view
controller conforms to
the AVAudioRecorder delegate.
If we start typing.
We can see that Xcode autocomplete
automatically shows us.
The functions available in
the AVAudioRecorder delegate.
Including AudioRecorder
did finish recording.
If you hit the return key, Xcode
will fill this function out for us.
This is the function we're going to use
to call the stop recording segue that
we set up earlier, and
move to the audio playback scene.
For now let's just add a print
statement to let us know when
AV audio recorder is finished,
right here where it says code.